pourquoi souhaites-tu être noby boy qui
ne souhaitent pas aux grands budapest
monsieur ainsi ma vie commence à
apprentis lobby boy débutant sous le
sévère commandement de monsieur gustave
achi beaucoup de clients les plus
précieux et les plus distingués de
l'hôtel venait pour lui je vous aime je
vous aime se fait de la dynamique cette
femme au plumard et y avait 84 ans
journée où les plus vieux
ce fut également l'époque où je
rencontrais agatha les charmantes elle
est si charmant il flatte avec toi oui
je vous donne ma bénédiction
je devins sont élevés il allait devenir
mon conseiller et mon protecteur
la police est là dis leur que je viens
tout de suite elle a été assassinée
et vous croyez que je lis tu es vous
êtes superbe darling je vous assure je
ne sais pas quelle crème ils vous sont
appliqués à la morgue mais je veux la
paix voici les dernières volontés et le
testament de maternité à monsieur
gustave h je lègue le tableau nommé
garçon à la pomme ouarkoye qui a vu sa
vache j'ai bien peur que ce soit moi
très cher
si jamais j'apprends que vous avez posé
un seul doigt sur ma mère vivante ou
morte je couche avec tous mes amis
[Musique]
faut faire un projet pour t'assurer cash
ça c'est un codé il te faudra une loupe
pour la lire mais le syndic ou et
comment retrouver le garçon à la pomme
sur boulangère pyjama il fonde aussi
c'est mon corps je veux des barrages à
chaque carrefour sur 50 km je veux un
barrage dans chaque gare / 100km beauté
je veux 50 hommes et des chiens
policiers près dans cinq minutes
vous ne pouvait l'arrêter juste parce
que c'est un foutu immigrés et lâchez
tout de suite bon la bi mode
as tu déjà été interrogé par les
autorités et lui a eu une occasion à
calvi a été arrêté et torturé par la
ministre appelle après la révolte du
désert alors tu connais le topo moto